JEN PERSON: Knock, knock.
ALEX LUCAS: Who's there?
JEN PERSON: Exploring
Cloud Identity.
ALEX LUCAS: Exploring
Cloud Identity, who?
JEN PERSON: Learn how to unify
access to products and services
with Cloud Identity in this
new series, "Who's There,
Exploring Cloud Identity."
ALEX LUCAS: I don't get it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN PERSON: Most
businesses depend
on a diverse array
of technologies
to operate day-to-day.
Your clients need a way to
interface with products,
like viewing products
via a website or an app.
Employees need to access company
services on their laptops,
tablets, and phones.
Companies need to manage
onboarding and off-boarding
employees in directories.
And the business may depend
on third-party services,
like customer management systems
and messaging applications.
Some of these services
may exist on premises.
But other services
are most useful
when they are accessible
outside of the office.
Personally, I both
love and loathe
that I can check my
work email on my devices
from any location.
So how can a business
effectively maintain
secure access to all
these technologies?
Well, one great solution to
this tangle of technologies
is Google Cloud Identity.
Cloud Identity is a unified
solution for your business's
identity needs.
It protects company data using
the BeyondCorp security model
and Google's threat
intelligence signals.
And it enables people
to access thousands
of apps with single sign on and
manage their company accounts
using the same process as
their personal Google accounts.
Cloud Identity helps your
company transition to the cloud
by integrating
with your existing
systems on a reliable,
trusted platform.
So to boil it all
down, Cloud Identity
is a suite of products that help
your company unify management
of people, apps, and devices.
Now if I went in
depth on everything
that Cloud Identity does, that
would be a very long video.
So rather than try to
squeeze all this information
into a single video, I've
decided to make this series,
"Who's There, Exploring
Cloud Identity."
I'll be talking about
four main facets
to Cloud Identity-- managing
users, devices, directories,
and apps.
We'll explore each
facet of Cloud Identity
in depth, starting with
managing app authentication
and authorization through
Cloud Identity platform.
ALEX LUCAS: Sounds great.
I'm excited to learn
more about Cloud Identity
and what it can
do for my company.
But I still didn't get the joke.
You should probably just
stick to programming.
JEN PERSON: Fair enough.
But what about this one?
Why did the programmer use VIM?
Because they couldn't
figure out how to exit!
No?
Exiting VIM.
[MUSIC PLAYING]